a challenge for tukey toussaint he's
facing one of the best offenses in the
league and he's doing it here at home
tonight making his fourth start of the
season his first career start against
the nats that'll bring up adam eaton who
had the day off
two
yesterday
two to eat matt disappeared he swings
over the top and tuki off to a good
start two up two down cabrera will be at
the plate with a fresh count to start
the top half of the second
and a swing of the miss high fastball
cabrera didn't get it at 96. tommy right
he's got a good heater tonight here's
luis garcia with one on one out
we'll be back in ciardi back is
marcankus and this ball is gone goodbye
how about that he had his first hit and
first rbis on friday night and now
tonight his first major league home run
a two-run shot to right center with kurt
suzuki aboard 410 feet the distance
and 20-year-old luis garcia is in the
home run column bang zoom goes garcia
it's the nationals two of the braves
nothing just snuck that one over the big
wall and he sat on a first pitch
fastball belt high and we talked about
his improved upper body strength and
utilizing his legs more and he turned on
that one and just snuck it over the
fence as carter kibum kid from marietta
and the nationals number one prospect
there's a big breaking ball inside
corner kaboom is caught looking tooky's
got his third strikeout and two are away
eric thames the batter he unloads on the
first pitch c
u
later
first as annette and that's the swing
we've been waiting for from eric thames
three-nothing nets it's a swing he's
been waiting for more importantly it won
that way in baltimore yesterday didn't
get out that one was a no doubter
first tater as a net what do you got
eric thames and now we dance bang zoom
goes thames with his first home run in a
nationals uniform and his third run
batted in 429
feet on that one is victor robles with
pop in the number nine spot tonight
let's try to go johnny cueto and quick
pitch him right there and it worked yep
that's it for the gnats so any ball off
the stretch now for the first time mark
caicos
three for five career against him
3-2 pitch runner goes ground ball that
is a fair ball down the right field line
rounding second heading for third ozona
ron washington waves him to the plate
there will be no throw making an rbi
double and the braves are on the board
as it's 3-1
austin riley who made a big splash last
year
hitting 11 homers in his first 29 big
league games
tailed off ended up hitting 226
and he's going to hit that bard ball
hard right up the middle and the braves
will turn the lead off walk in the
double into two runs thanks to riley so
now with the bases loaded it's three and
two here's the nats catcher kurt suzuki
he needs a strike the 3-2
check swing the pitch is low they appeal
and no so it's a bases loaded walk to
kurt suzuki he'll pick up rbi number
seven turner will score and the
nationals lead it four to two here's the
catcher travis darno here's the pitch so
we're gonna line drive to right that's
going to fall in for a base hit toward
the line headed for the plate is swanson
eaton's throw is cut off by thames and
over the third goes freeman so darno
shoots a single to right freeman over to
third it's now the nationals four in the
braves three and here comes the nasa
league player of the week juan soto with
the bases loaded soto one for two with a
solo home run against this left-hander
getting under one out to center carrying
inciarte
close twice
the nats have stranded five in their
first four innings at the blatant honey
bowls coming out to the mound destructo
leads off
kind of pitched down and hammered it to
left
see
you
later as juba cabrera five homers this
year most of them from the right side
and the nets
increase their lead fastball in drop the
barrel on it
stay hot as drubal cabrera and i'm
sticking through he's the most
underrated player in baseball he's 11
for 21
with four homers and eight rbis
right-handed now
will smith facing juan soto leading off
the ninth inning first pitch drilled the
center field moving back in circle
looking up going going gone goodbye
a blast over the center field wall for
juan soto the national league player of
the week has done it again
that's his seventh home run in 12 games
played so far this year rbi number 15
puts the nationals in front by three
it's washington six atlanta three
bang
zoom goes soto
445
feet
he just missed the grand slam earlier
tonight first pitch fastball right down
the middle and soto just
watched and admired it that was
demolished
wow
will smith took exception the way soto
watched it
adam do all the batter
fly ball well hit soto retreats that
ball is over his head that ball is gone
duvall with a two-strike two-run homer
and the braves have made it a one-run
game boy it looks so much like the other
night in florida
when he took a pitch on the outer half
glab and absolutely pulled this thing to
left field yeah too good at bats there
back to back marchaik is now devolved
and the braves are down to their last
out in the ninth inning and it's dansby
swanson
fly ball well hit center robles going
back to the track to the wall and it's
gone
dansby with a walk-off homer in the
ninth
unbelievable
[Music]
atlanta with two two run homers in the
ninth inning stunned the nationals
and their rebuilt bullpen
atlanta wins round one of this ten round
heavyweight fight in 2020 in a walk-off
home run fashion
from dansby swansea to straight away
center dansby pretty much said we don't
need to get to freddy yeah i'm gonna end
this thing
he knew it you could see freddy behind
him putting the fist up
look hudson was going nothing but
fastballs and dansby smart hitter
and look where he went straight away
right away didn't try to pull it
back spend it ball game first career
walk off home run for dansby it was a no
doubter
hudson in disbelief
as the nationals bullpen implodes in the
ninth inning in atlanta will smith picks
up the win
atlanta
will maintain first place in the east